[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين الكرام الى
الفقره وجها لوجه فيها نتوقف عند ابرام
رئيس الموريتانيه السابق محمد ولد عبد
العزيز
لحلفا سياسي مع مواطنين موريتانيين مقيمين
في اوروبا واعداده وفق مصادرها اعلاميه
مطلعه لتكوين ما وصفت بانها جبهه تغيير
سياسي مناهضه للنظام القائم في موريتانيا
مشاهدينا الكرام عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من
واكشوط السيد المستشاركي احمد الناطق
الرسمي باسم جبهه التغيير سيد البكي احمد
الكويري اهلا بكم ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك
على تلبيس هذه الدعوه اهلا وسهلا
معي في الجانب المقابل المشاهدين الكرام
دائما والشوط سيد دباب ولد بن يو كان نائب
البرلمانيه عن الاغلبيه الرئاسيه سيد همم
وسهلا بك ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك ايضا على
تلبيه هذه الدعوه
اهلا وسهلا اهلا وسهلا بكم مرحبا مرحبا
بكم كل ترحيب وسؤالي ما تعليقكم على
تحركات الرئيس الموريتاني السابق في
اوروبا خلال فتره فحوصاته الطبيه في
الخارج كما توصف والاعلان عن ابرمه لحلف
سياسي مع حركه المشعل الافريقي اطرح عليك
السؤال الاول ان سيد دباب والبنوك النائب
البرلماني عن الاغلبيه الرئاسيه مرحبا من
جديد
شكرا استاذ اهلا وسهلا بكم ومرحبا في
الاستضافه همم على كل حال هذه
التحركات همم تحركات
همم لا تقدم جديده للساحه السياسيه لان من
يقفون عليها او من تولى اداره
بها هم همم
همم حركات سياسيه او اتجاهات سياسيه رفضها
الشعب الموريتاني منذ فتره طويله رفضها
المواطن موريتاني لم تقدم خطاب جامعا ولو
تقدم خطابا توافقيا انما قدمت خطاب
الشقاقي خطابا انشقاق المجتمع انما قدمت
خطابا لتفريقه المجتمع ويشردمته وتفكيكه
الى مكونات هذه الحركه السياسيه التي
للاسف الشديد يتحدث عنها او تحالفت او
يقال ان الرئيس السابق تحالف معها هي حركه
معروفه هي اول حركه ووريتانيه طالبه في
الانفصال هي اول حركه مرتين ثانيه بنت
خطابها على همم الانقسام العرقي في
المواطن في الوطن ثاني واحاولته في كل مره
استغلاله ظروف والبناء على هذه والبناء
على هذا الانقسام التوظيف في خطابه
السياسي وفي كل مره ايضا كانت ضد الشعب ضد
الدوله لان الساعه احداث موريتانيا 1948
حيث كانت الحركه الجزء من المؤ ضد الدوله
الموريتاني وجزء من المؤامره التي استهدفت
الشعب الموريتاني ان ياكل استهدبت النيد
منه وحاولت بكل السبل عن استعاده الفتنه
واشعال حرب بنوريتاني بين موريتانيا هذه
الحركه او هذا التحالف لا اعتقد انه يقدم
جديدا بقدر ما يضعوا همم مؤيد او يضع من
اقدم عليه في ورطه اكبر مما كانوا فيها
كان على السيد الرئيس السابق ان يتوجه الى
القضاء لمعالجه مشكلته مع القضاء
لحسم موقفي نفسه
اليه قبل ان يذهب الى فرنسا الى اوروبا
لتحالفات فهي اقرب الى تحالفاتها واهميه
همم المواطن الموري ثاني ولن تقدم اشياء
للساحه السياسيه
احمد الدكوري الناطق الرسمي باسم جبهه
التغيير كما تابعه تحت اشراف الرئيس
السابق رفقه وفد من
هذه الحركه حركه افلام تكوين لموسفت بانها
منصه للتشاور والمتابعه تسمى ملتزمون من
اجل موريتانيا موحده البعض وصفا بان هذا
التحالف لا يقدم شيئا واخرون وصفوه بانه
تحالف مشبوه ونده به كيف تركب انت حركات
رئيس السابقه في اوروبا خلال فتره فحوصاته
الطبيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا على
الاستضافه اولا همم هذه المنصه التي همم
اشرف الرئيس السابق محمد بن عبد العزيز
على همم
تنسيقها في همم باريس هي منصه عنوانها
الرئيسي والعريض وهو ملتزمون بموريتانيا
موحده ومن الظلم والاجحابي بمن التحق بهذه
المنطقه
الذين اتصلوا بالرئيس السابق من بروكسل
ومن باريس ومن المانيا ومن مختلف الدول
الغربيه
ومن حتى من امريكا وهم منطلبوا منه ان
ينسق همم معهم هذه همم من الظلم لهم ان
يتم تجاوزهم وذكر اسلام همم وحدها دون
التطرق الى هؤلاء هذه المنصه التي تسمى
ملتزمون بموريتانيا موحده هي منصه تفتح
فرصه امام مختلف الطيف السياسي الموريتاني
لتشاور حول مستقبل موريتانيا موريتانيا
موحده اما بخصوص هذه الحركه اي حركه افلام
وماضيها السيء بالنسبه لبعض الموريتانيين
فهي حركه عندما اتصلت بالرئيس السابق محمد
بن عبد العزيز وطرح عليها العديد من
الاسئله فيما يشع عنها سلفا
اكدت ان كل ما كان يشع عنها هو عمل
استخباراتيا كانت تقوم به المخابرات
لتشويه صورتها هنا نحن في همم منصه
ملتزمون بموريتانيا موحده نقول عليكم
بالظواهر والله يتولى السرائر هما
احتمالين فقط لهذه الحركه اما ان يكون ما
قد اشيع عنها صحيح
التوبه تجب ما قبلها فقد تابوا على يد
الرئيس السابق واعلن التزامهم بوحده
موريتانيا وهذا ما قبله ويعطي الفرصه لاي
مواطن موريتاني ان يناقش ويسهر من اجل
مستقبل موريتانيا موحده واما ان يكون
الامر عار من الصحه كما يدعي هؤلاء وهي
مؤامره حكم ضدهم من قبل المخابرات وهذا
يجعلهم قد اوضحوا جهه نظرهم الحقيقيه
والسليمه اي انهم ملتزمون بموريتانيا
موحده بمعنى نعم طيب ملتزمون بموريتانيا
موحده من بامكانه ان يعارض ذلك سيد دباب
وكنا قبل البرلمان عن الاغلبيه الرئاسيه
خاصه وان هذا الحلف السياسي الذي ابرمه
الرئيس السابق همم
وجهها انتقادات شديده لنظام الرئيس محمد
ولد الشيخ الغزواني اكد ان تاسيسه جاء
وقوفا ضد الانتكاسات الخطيره والمتتاليه
التي شهدها النظام الديمقراطي في
موريتانيا الاخيره يعني عدد تراجع سواء
الحريات الفرديه والجماعيه انتهاكات
متكرره للقانون فساد محسوبيه زبونيه سوء
الاداره تدهور الحاله المعيشيه للمواطنين
تسارع التضخم ازدياد الفقر تواغل النزعه
الجهويه والقبليه والعشائريه والطائفيه
الى اخر ذلك الى اخر ذلك كيف ترد انت على
ذلك
شكرا
اولا استغرب من الاخ الزميل ان يتحدث
ويسعى الى تبريئه حركه افلام لان حركه
افلام خطابها معروف وخطابها منشور وموجود
وليس بحاجه لمن يعيد ما همم لمن يعيد
انتاجه ولمن يعيد خطاب اسلام خطاب معروف
خطاب سوري خطاب شرائح خطاب عراقي موجود
على الانترنت وكل ما يريد الاطلاع عليها
ان يطلع عليه وخطابها ما فيش طالب جزء
ثاني وهذا ليس جديده وهذا ولم تتراجع
افلام عن هو لم تقول لهم في يوم من الايام
كانت موجوده في حكم الرئيس السابق وكانت
حركه ونفس خطافه اليوم الذي تغير اليوم
حتى يعود الرئيس السابق محمد عبد العزيز
لي تحالف معها وهو من كان بالامس القريب
وكل الاوصافها ويعتبروها غيره صالحه
ويعتبرها حركه عصريه وجهها
اغرب جدا من همم من هذه العوده لحركه فلان
ثم بعد ذلك همم ملتزمون من يريد من يريد
الالتزام بموريتانيا موحده عليه الانخراط
في صفوف الاغلبيه الداعمه للرئيس محمد
للشيخ الغزواني رئيس هو من سعى حسيتها
لهذا الرئيس هذا الرئيس هو ومن سعى من اول
يوم اصوله للسلطه الى بناء توافق وطنيه
جامع لكل موريتانيا هذا الرئيس هو من وقع
في وجه الاحتقان السياسي الذي كان قائما
الذي كان يؤدي الى انهيار لبلادي وتحولها
وتحول البلاد الى حرب فئويه طاحنه
جاهدا الى ان يوقف واذا ان يوقف تلك
المشاكل واذا ان يوقف تلك الممارسات التي
كانت سائده هو من بنى اجماعا وطنيا وهو من
اسس الدوله الاجتماعي الموريتانيه التي
يعيشها المواطن والوريتا اليوم
بعض الموريتاني اليوم يعيش في بحبوحه رغم
الظروف ورقم الصعوبه الحياه ولكن الدوله
اليوم تقف تقفوا بقوه وتقف بحجم في وجه
همم وتقعه بحجم من اجل تطبيق رؤيه فخامه
رئيس الجمهوريه الرؤيه الاجتماعيه القائمه
على اشراك المواطنين القائمه على
الاستفتاءات المواطنين من خارج البلد
اليوم سيعطيك بعض الارقام اليوم هناك اكثر
من 600 لهم مواطن موريتاني استفاده من
التامين الصحي في عهد الرئيس الحالي هل
استفادت هذه هذه سابقا اليوم هناك اكثر من
1000 همم مدرسه همم منذ حكم الرئيس الحالي
وفي المناطق الهشه وفي المناطق الفطيره
التي كانت محرومه من كل خدمات الدوله هل
همم لا يعتبر
وهذا عمل مهمه اليوم في عهد الرئيس الحالي
تم توفير صندوق بقيمه 25 مليار تشغيل
الشباب لا يعتبر
وهذا يتقدم ولا لا يعتبر وهذا محاربه
للفقري ومحاربه للتهم طيب ولا يعتبروا هذا
مسعا جديا وفعلا من اجل موريتانيا موحده
موريتانيا التي يعيش كل من سنه تستفيد كل
فئاتها وكل طبقاتها من الشعب اقول لك وهو
بكل بساطه عنه همم هذا النظام رغم الظروف
الصعبه التي وجدها امامه ورقم الوضعيه
الصعبه التي وجد امامه التي وجدت الدوله
الموريته التي وجد فيها الدوله
الموريتانيه ورقم كل ذلك ورقم الازمات
اللاحقه التي تتالت رغم كل ذلك تمكن من
الخروج بموريتانيا اليوم الى بر الامان
تمكن اليوم من الوقوف بمتمكن اليوم من خلق
اجماع وطني غير مسبوق نحن لا حضرنا قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع اجماع عن وطنيه شاركت في كل
احزاب السياسيه معارضه
اتخابيه توافقيه هذا لم يحدث السابقه في
عهد الرئيس السابق هذا لم يحدث رؤس
التوفيقات مهمه وفعاله طيب اذا هذا
التقدير السلبي من قبل هذا الحلف السياسي
لحص الرئيس الحالي محمد ولد الشيخ
الغزواني حتى اعود اليك سيد البكيري احمد
الكويري الناطق الرسمي باسم جبهه تتغير
هذا التقييم مردود عليه وما جاء في بيان
هذا الحلف السياسي مجافا للحقيقه والبعض
يذهب حتى الى القول ان الغريق يتعلق بقشه
بمعنى ان البعض يقول ان الرئيس السابق في
منطق همم ضعف في هذه المرحله بل وايضا في
منطقي تصفيه حسابات سياسيه غير مبرره جهه
الرئيس الحالي وتنتابهم حتى الحيره حول
مواصفات
وتحركاته السياسيه الحاليه وهو المتهم اا
بال فساد ويسالون طيف على الاقل يسال هل
ياتي التغيير من من لفظهم همم الشعب يقول
معارضوا الرئيس السابق مساء الرئيس
طيب اولا اييه
استغرب الاخ الضيف من دفاعي ومحاوله
افلام يبدو انه لم يستمع جيدا الى كلامي
فلم احاول تبرئه الحركه انما قلت عليكم
بالظواهر والله يتولى السرائر لقد اعتذرت
وتابت هذه الحركه من ماضيها ان كان لها
ماضي السيد ونحن لا نغلق الباب في وجه اي
موريتانيين يحاول من جهته ان يساعد في
توحيد وبناء موريتانيا
هذه الارقام التي ذكرها ضيفك انا هو من
استغرب من اقتصاره على هذه الارقام
همم
دمشكله رقم 6 لماذا لا يجعلها الارقام
بالملايين هي ليست ارقام على ارض الواقع
انا استغربوا من همم
جرئته همم اخذ الارقام بالملايين 50 مليار
35 مليار تم دمج الشباب تم هذا لا يوجد
منه اي شيء على ارض الواقع انما هي
مليارات تذهب الى جيوب متنفعين والمفسدين
الذين داب هذا النظام على تدويرهم
واخراجهم من قبورهم
لكيدات وقراءه
على ما تقوله على هذه الاتهامات التي
تسوقها بالفساد
طبيعي هنالك مئات الالاف القرائن والادله
اول هذه القرائن ان هذه الميزانيه التي
تضاعفت الرئيس الحالي همم محمد بن الشيخ
الغزواني لم تنعكس على الحاله المعيشيه
ولا البنى التحتيه ولا الاقتصاد ولا اي
شيء في هذا البلد لم يحاول هذا الرئيس ان
يقوم باي مشروع الا وفشل فيه قام بتدشين
الحمله الزراعيه ابانا انقطاع الطماطم من
المغرب فلم تقوم قائمه للزراعه من يومها
من يومها قام هذا الرئيس محمد
مدريد
الذي وجدوا دراسته مكتمله قبله
وهل ياتي الحل من من لفظهما الشعب يقول
انصار الرئيس الحالي همم سيد دربكه يا
احمد متى لفظهم الشعب متى لفظهم الشعب هذا
هذه مجرد ادعاءات وكلام مردود
من خلال الرئيس الحالي من انتخبه ومن كان
يعرفه لو لم يقدمه محمد بن عبد العزيز
الرئيس السابق لترشيح من كان يعطي صوتا
واحدا للرئيس الحالي لو لم يقف خلفه
الرئيس الماضي وهي من السيئاته طبعا عن
انني رئيس السابق من اكبر السيئاته هو
دعمه لهذا الرئيس
في عشريه النماء عشريه الازدهار لم يحافظ
وهذا الرئيس الحالي
ومن بنيه تحتيه ومن تقدم حتى
التي لا تكلفه ميزانيه ولا تكلفه اي شيء
يتحدث عن عشريه ماء وازدهار في جانب
المقابل
بالنسبه لرئيس السابقه تتحدث عن عشريه
اييه سوداء ويقول لك رئيس الحالي
سيد ولد الغزواني لم يقم باي مشروع الا
وفشله لذلك موقع اخباري عن مصادر مقربه من
الرئيس السابق يقول ان ولد عبد العزيز
سيعلن قريبا عن جبهه سياسيه مضاده لنظام
الرئيس الغزواني تسمى تحالف قوى التغيير
ستضم في صفوفها عددا من الموريتانيين
المقيمين في الخارج هدفها هو فرض تغيير
سياسي سلما في موريتانيا انصار الرئيس
السابق يقولون انها ان موريتانيا تحتاج
فعلا لهذا التغيير بعد حصيله الرئيس
الحالي كيف تعاقب على مذهب اليه ضيف لو
سمحت
انا كل حاجه اعتقد انه من الاولى
بالرئيس السابق
وداعمميه ان يحل مشكلتهم مع القضاء لانها
هناك مشكله مع القضاء وهناك تهم ثقيله
وهناك ملف ثقيل لا يزال امام الرئيس
السابق وعليه اولا ان يواجه القضاء وعليه
اولا ان يبرئ نفسه
من التجاوزات ومن التهم الموجات المواجهه
اليه والتهم الثقيله والتي لو وجهت لاي
رئيس يحترم نفسه ويحترم مساره من العمل
السياسي نهائيا ولكن للاسف الشديد ما نراه
اليوم
جدا ان يتحدث
وتتحدث الشعب الموريتاني ومن رفضهم ومن لا
يمثلون شيئا اليوم في الساحه السياسيه ان
يتحدث في التغيير وان يتحدث باسم مواجهه
الرئيس الحالي فيتحدثوا بانه سيقدمون
للشعب الموريتاني ما لم يقدموه له خلال
عشريه عصريه سابقه ما الذي قدمه هؤلاء
خلال عشريه السابقه حتى يحن اليه الشعب
الموريتاني اليوم الا يتذكرون الظرفيه
التي خرجوا فيها من موريتانيا اليه تذكرنا
على الاضافيه مغادراتهم لقد كنا هنا في
العاصمه هناك شوط حيث تحولت الى ثكنات
عسكريه في كل احيائها ما السبب انها سياسه
الرئيس السابق انها سياسه النظام السابق
انها سياسه تدميريه التي تهزها النظام
السابق السياسه التي كانت
تجيء الى حرق البلد السياسيه التي كانت
تتجه الى حرب الى حرب في قويه حرب شرائحيه
كبيره لا تبقي ولا تذر من الاوقاف هذه من
اوقف هذه الحرب من اوقف هذه المشكله من من
من خرج بالبلاد من تلك الازمه الطاحنه
ووضعها اليوم في هذا المكان المكان الان
اليوم الموريتانيون يتناقشون بينهم
يتحاورون بينهم اليوم هناك حوارات مفتوحه
بين لطيف السياسي في موريتاني لا غالبه
ولا مغلوب لا مهمش لا مطحون الكل يقول
رايه ويبدي برايي والكل يساهم في بناء
موريتانيا سواء كان معارضا او مؤيدا لا
فرق بين ذلك اما ما قبل ذلك فندركه جيدا
هل ندركه جيدا اذا كان الاخر الكريم لا
يدركه واذا كان يعتقد ان الشعب الموريتاني
ذكرته ضعيفه او يلعب على ذلك مره ثانيه
اذاكرته قويه جدا جدا الظروف التي مرت بها
الفتره ويعرفون جيدا ما قدمه الرئيس
الحالي الرئيس الحالي خرج بموريتانيا من
شافها عاشور وفي النهارد الى وضعيه اليوم
نحسده عليها
دقيقه واحده في كل المجلات
وعلى الشعب الموريتاني ان يتمسك بخيارات
الرئيس
يسامحك ففي تطوير وتقنيه بلادي طيب
استسمحك انتهى الوقت دقيقه واحده واختم
معك ضيفي سيد البكي احمد لكوريري يقول لك
ذاكره الشعب الموريتاني ليست ضعيفه على
الرئيس السابق ان يبرئ نفسه من التهم التي
تطاله اولا باختصار في اقل من دقيقه لو
سمحت انتهى الوقت
همم الرئيس السابق محمد بن عبد العزيز هو
من يطالب اليوم باجراء هذه المحاكمه لكي
يبرئه القضاء ان كان هذا القضاء عادلا
ولكي يبرئ نفسه هؤلاء الذين يحكمون البلاد
اليوم هم من يمتنعون عن تقديم الرئيس
السابق لمحاكمه
لمعرفتهم ان الملف سياسي في جوهره لو لم
يقدم الرئيس السابق على بدائره السياسي
وعلى رفضه لهؤلاء المفسدين الذين يحكمون
البلاد اليوم لما تمت استدعائه ولما ولما
تم التحقيق معه جميع الذين شملتهم همم هذه
همم هذا الملف ملف العصريه تم التبريدتهم
وتعيينهم لانهم يناصرون الرئيس الحالي
ويوافقون على الفساد معه بالنسبه للرئيس
اتفضل على كل التسمحك لان الوقت داهمنا
الرئيس السابق سيعود سواء في ال 20 او في
الحادي من 20 من هذا الشهر وسنتابع كل
تطورات النشاط
السياسيا كبيرا يتم بموجبه تغيير السلمي
لهذه السلطه الفاشله التي اختفى عنا
رئيسها ولم نجد له اثر سنتابع كل ذلك على
كلنا نشكركم جزيلا شكرا على هذه الحلقه
المستشار البكي احمد الكويتي باسم جبهه
التغيير شكرا جزيلا لك وكل الشكر جزيلا لك
ايضا في الجانب المقابل على تربيه دعوتنا
ايضا السيد دباب والبنوك النائب
البرلمانيه عن الاغلبيه الرئاسيه كنتما
معنا من واكشوط في فقره وجهها